what's that believe nation I'm Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problems
and today I'm excited because in
launching a new series we're kick
starting a new series fun we'll see how
it works if you guys like it I'm calling
it the best of Kickstarter where I look
at three different campaigns that are
currently happening right now on
Kickstarter show some of their videos
and I'd love to know what do you think
of them would you support them do you
enjoy them and I'd love to hear from you
lo if you want this series to continue
and I'll keep on promoting some
different entrepreneurs with some
innovative products on Kickstarter so up
first is Arsenal which dubs itself as
the intelligence camera assistant and
promises to unlock the potential of your
DSLR or mirrorless camera and capture
amazing images in any conditions let's
talk about taking the perfect photo
first compose the shot check the
histogram adjust the exposure focus on
your subject compute the hyperfocal
distance to keep everything sharp enable
bracketing to get more dynamic range add
a neutral density filter update the
exposure and then take the shot we built
a better way
[Music]
today's DSLR and mirrorless cameras have
amazing optics and sensors but they do
very little to actually help you take a
good photo
finding the right sentence involves a
series of complex techniques and
formulas as an engineer with a
background in artificial intelligence I
knew I could build a tool to simplify
the process I wanted something that
would let me focus on the compositions
but would handle the details for me so I
created arsonist the world's first AI
photography assistant with one tap
arsenal fine settings to take the best
photo possible Arsenal's AI searches
thousands of images in its database to
success could set it next it fine Tunes
the suggestions by analyzing 18
different factors Arsenal uses
state-of-the-art machine learning to
help you take a great photo in any
condition
[Music]
[Music]
many of the memorable shots you see
today are captured by combining multiple
exposures through a labor-intensive
process called photo second with Arsenal
you can do this in seconds to capture
all the details and seams with high
dynamic range get everything in sharp
focus and create long exposures without
buying expensive filters using these
advanced techniques Arsenal lets you go
beyond the limitations of your camera's
sensor or lint four times when you want
complete control you can wirelessly
adjust manual settings see a live
preview and trigger the shutter all from
up to 100 feet away
Arsenal also improves the experience of
reviewing photos in the field you can
flip through the photos on your camera
zoom in to check out details at full
resolution then share your favorite
photos right from your phone
and finally Arsenal makes it easy to
capture stunning time-lapse
it automatically adjusts the exposure in
changing lights giving you a smooth
day-to-night transition you can even
watch a high-def preview of your
time-lapse while it's being taken
whether you're a pro who is already
mastered manual shooting or you just
bought your first DSLR Arsenal can help
take your photography to the next level
so before you replace your gear try
upgrading your techniques with Arsenal
Arsenal is already being tested in the
field now I need your help to ramp up
production by supporting our campaign
stay you can be one of the first to get
our we've got exclusive rewards for our
early backers and some awesome stretch
goals in the work I'm really excited
about the photos I've been getting with
us I can't wait to share it with you and
see all the amazing photos you'll see
[Music]
all right that's Arsenal up next is bolt
drones which promises to introduce a
whole new flight experience and
innovative and versatile first person
view drone at a radical price check it
out piloting drones is a relatively new
activity that most people are starting
to explore we wanted to design a drone
that introduced as many people as
possible
so the first person view drone
experience without breaking the bank
introducing a whole new flight
experience the bolt is an innovative and
versatile first person view drone
available at a radical price it's a
complete ready to fly out-of-the-box
solution that's easy and safe to pilot
the drone for everyone there are three
ways to fly first for beginners to start
flying simply turn on the drone and turn
on the controller the two will sync up
and pair and you can takeoff the drone
features altitude stabilization and a
beginner's mode that makes picking up
the basics of breeze learn how to safely
and confidently maneuver and control
your drone next for those ready to
expand their horizons attach the screen
to the controller and start piloting the
drone further away simply turn on the
drone and the screen the
camera on the drone will automatically
sync and broadcast a live
high-definition feed mount the screen on
the controller and you're ready to go
finally for those ready for the whole
first person you experience swap the
screen into the goggles and prepare for
a whole new flight experience immerse
yourself into the world of fpv piloting
and cruise around high in the sky or try
your hand at fpv drone racing and
experience the incredible excitement
from every twist and turn drone racing
is a new and exciting sport that is
quickly growing around the world using
fpv goggles pilots raced our drones
around courses to compete for the
fastest times it is truly the sport of
the future the bolt can be used to
experience drone racing at a fraction of
the current price
it's an exciting virtual reality flying
experience the bolt drone was designed
and tested in Los Angeles by a team of
expert product designers aerospace
engineers and drone enthusiasts it's
built on a carbon fiber frame that
offers unmatched performance and
durability the HD camera provides
crystal-clear video and photos and the
battery easily slides in and out for
quick swapping the drone design is
modular so that individual parts can be
replaced the result is a highly
maneuverable lightweight and aerodynamic
drone the bolt features a unique and
innovative ftv viewing system that
allows seamless transition from
traditional viewing on the controller to
fpv viewing using goggles we're excited
to offer the bolt drone at a radical
price
traditionally consumers purchase their
drones at a high price point since
importers wholesalers and retailers mark
up the price of a drone up to five
hundred percent by cutting out the
middlemen we are able to sell directly
to you and pass on the savings the bulk
drone was designed to introduce as many
people as possible the first person view
piloting and racing without breaking the
bank with our finished prototypes ready
for production
we're here on Kickstarter to raise the
money we need for our first batch with
both drones we want to make first person
view piloting and raising accessible to
everyone
with your support this can be the start
of something big thanks for watching
alright that's bolt droned and last but
not least we'll give mine up for FY bead
London which does itself to be the
world's smartest ten bag and the kina
will like this one just check it
[Music]
I'm interested in getting your handbag
like yours can you tell me more about it
a dead phone is the perfect way to ruin
a good day but with a smart handbag
you'll never have to worry about that
again simply drop your phone into the
charging pocket and keep your phone up
and running for as long as you are no
more searching at length for important
items in your bag with this handbag
everything has this place ready for a
quick retrieval when needed whether at
work or traveling or anywhere in between
our London smart handbag keeps your
items organized and safe to protect your
belongings from theft each handbag
unlocks only to your unique fingerprint
or access via the bluetooth app our
smart bag is also equipped with RFID
protected card holders to keep your
credit card and other sensitive
information safe and the Bluetooth
connectivity feature automatically
notifies your phone if your bag lives
inside but we know none of these
features matter much if the handbag
you'll is beautiful rest assured we
spent several months diligently working
not only on all the amazing smart
features but on the eye-catching
luxurious leather classic style this bag
is the ultimate smart fashion accessory
so those are the three Kickstarter
campaigns I wanted to highlight all the
links are down below I love to know what
do you guys think did you like the
camera assistant did you like the bulb
drones or did you like the smart handbag
if you were going to buy one which one
were your favorite leave it down the
comments below also this is again a test
of a new potential series do you want
this best of Kickstarter ideas to
continue next month or not let me know
down in the comments we'll see what you
have to say thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
absolutely